[музика]
сіль же шляхом укус облави як заганяти
художник вакцин but much of war.
і
така чітко башта херсона ярлики тиковий
центр культурою щит ціну за беремо участь
зі своїх ліній так і буду
будувати the students до вас або місця до
з музичного та театрального фестивалю
у нас середа середа вже
10 зріла для того всі проводите такі
заходи
амун кальсонах баші тейк мало ніжність і
на студентське фестивальне місце
[музика]
я сам, ніж сонність
просто 30 rocky fry живу херсоне приїхавши
її знаю ми всі син шуй херсоном куплю я
знав там і це було дуже
тикові
і
перспективну працюючи курс гуртом порахувати
такий ранок взагалі не поміщаєш литі
vocal їх ти набрати відвід
руху тут силою від спинного за свою
історію з пітьми школами
набагато цікавіше шайбу краще ніж живу
небезпечне поле від розуму і не зробили їх
з майонезу мене нехай так май але
табуляція мої але от якусі так от сюди
вклавши в майстер
створюючи логріани укусу вихід рецепт
сродниться ти ж ви ж усередині це
подія всередині картини та
vertical опозиція для миття можуть вусика
віші було spilota за масами люди найбільш
вулиця що я буду херсон пізно та ми
Усе
моделі були
[музика]
наступне освітлення буде костюма як
в цей
слова друга
руки спочатку це під мостом
якийсь супер місток добре знайдемо
місце де хотів на перегон подивитися
потім нам потрібно тобі the less
ясновидець потім дві будки
ціни народний художник поліна райту
ранку
збивав вона так ми стоцькі sweet своїм
творінням нікого на вигляд творила флешках
[музика]
загалом це наша поліна тільки така
спеціалізована поліна
ми вирішили взяти і цей сюжет і 7 він
допрацював
трафарети
[музика]
називається колекція primary поліни
рейку тобто вони такі чорно білі
такі привиди
трошки такий якийсь такий рентген
тому що на перший погляд може
здатися що полина така вся райдужна
така мальовнича
експресивна але вона як я відчуваю все
таки пройшла через
масу трагічних якихось таких подій
ось і вони
відображені в
колекції
вдома старі вони етапі
важливо
[музика]
а
ще
я
г
[оплески]
а
коли я приїхала сюди, я просто була
вражена тому що це щось таке
неймовірне та прийшла до хлопців з ідеєю
зробити саме фешен колекцію таку
щоб щоб просто ось ах
мені подобається
натхнення мети у житті
так ще
може 50 тисяч людей не можна
я лечу з духовими до мене і
armani на
декавалер
продукт ирина а кому включили у тому що
це ти знову
ви джер майстерності з доларом
природних типових для
проти випусків
[музика]
хто ж ти не маленький днів і уклав
ароматна і кована вже
повинен бути любить меча ну або були всі
робота називається в дорога дурою
[музика]
вона чому спочила мальва ти
весел 69 руки вас знову років створила
історію своєї життя
історія в
ось совість їх краєвидах і нікуди його
на принесла настін
[музика]
можна побачите
я перестала злилися
весни вистачало або покарало імені
письменника ні на чому тому ми і ви вирішили
полотна привести до ви привезли полотні
леви точного я багата раз побачив ми
буквально там тричі
розминулась вана комарова ти
весь дім буду і ніг їх розмахувала і все
проект через хизуємося і ось нас вона теж
як і раніше надихає ми приїжджаємо
сюди дивимося якісь нові елементи та
перероблюваних вона надихалася всім
чим бачила ходила в плавні та дивилася
якісь там журнали це безцінно просто
щось
що є всередині може ось ви
виплеснутися ось у цей такий загадковий
і чудовий світ
і вона це дозволило статися
лімфом свинина
тому взяв нас його адже ти побачилися
пред'являтися будинок на кому
поодинці
66 рублів і ядро ​​win32 вати і з встиг
ства на кисті
у
[музика]